[MUSIC PLAYING]
JUNE WU: Hi, everyone.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
My name is June,
and I am a Googler
on the global business
strategy team based
in 1098 in Mountain View.
I'm super excited
to introduce you
to the Dover
Quartet, who I'm very
lucky to call personal friends.
I just saw them yesterday
perform at the Green Music
Center in Sonoma, and
they did a phenomenal job,
and they'll be performing
some of the pieces they
played yesterday for you today.
They are finishing
up their US tour.
And basically right
after this concert,
they're going to be
jetting off and going
to the next performance, and
eventually head into Germany.
I don't want to speak
too much, because I
want them to introduce
themselves and tell you more
about themselves and the music.
But I did want to
introduce the four of them.
So we have Joel and
Bryan on violin,
and then Camden on the
cello, and Milena--
Milena on the viola.
The Dover Quartet was recently
named a quartet in residence
for the Kennedy Center in
DC, which is amazing news, so
congrats to them.
And they're also
the official quartet
in residence at Northwestern
University, where
they currently teach.
They also just performed
at Carnegie Hall
with superstar violinist Janine
Jansen and pianist Jean-Yves
Thibaudet.
They came out with
two CDs last year
and they are available
on Google Play Music,
so you should check them out.
Search Dover Quartet,
and it should come up.
Milena, I'm just
going to hand it over
to you so you can
talk a bit more
about the quartet and the music.
MILENA PAJARO-VAN
DE STADT: Yeah.
We're so excited to be here.
We're really happy that
so many of you came.
It's going to be a lot of fun.
We formed about nine years
ago while we were all
still in undergrad, which
is where most of us met,
although the two
violinists over there
have known one another since
they were 13 years old, which
is pretty cool.
But yeah, we've basically
been married to one another
since those nine years ago.
We were all at a
conservatory in Philadelphia
called the Curtis
Institute of Music.
And the chamber music was a
big part of education there,
so we were all playing in
multiple different groups
every year that we were there,
and we were all friends.
We all admired and loved
one another's playing.
And actually, Camden
and I from the outset
when we entered
school, we started
playing with one another,
and just loved it.
And basically, we
were in a group
together since that
first week of school.
We never were not
in a group together,
so we've been together
for even longer.
What's that, like 11 years?
And Joel and Bryan
as well, they were
in a quartet together
the year they
entered Curtis, which was
the year before Camden and I.
So eventually one
day, the two halves
of us, a quote unquote
"bottomless quartet"
and a "topless quartet"
joined together
to form a full quartet.
We loved playing
with each other,
and very quickly,
we had this thing
that we call the
relationship talk.
Like, is this just for school?
Is it just a fling, or is
this for the long term?
And we were all
on the same page.
And our first big
mark of commitment
was applying for a master's
degree together as a group.
So we went to Rice
University in Houston
where they have a special
program for string quartets
where they take
one group every two
years to do a masters degree
specializing in string quartet.
So we went there.
And from there, we
moved back to Philly,
which is where we're now based.
Even though we do
teach at Northwestern,
we still call Philly home.
And now, we just tour
full-time, teach at Northwestern
part-time, and this is our life.
CAMDEN SHAW: Yeah, that's true.
We give about 140 concerts
a year all over the world.
And you can imagine all
the travel days that
go into something like that.
But it's wonderful when you're
in a place like California
and you can go to beer tastings,
and wine tastings, and things
like that, so we
don't do too badly.
And we also never get to perform
in a place with a projector.
[LAUGHTER]
So since none of you
guys really know us,
we thought we'd show
you this trailer.
We're actually embarking on
a really interesting journey.
We have actually
completed the filming
for a documentary that will
be a full-length documentary
with a wonderful director,
who actually, he produced
and directed this movie
called "Chops," if you get
a chance to watch it, which
is about young jazz musicians,
and it was really
incredible, really inspiring.
And so we approached him
about doing a documentary
about chamber music.
The reason being, we're
traveling all the time,
and people always
ask is what we do.
And what we tell them
that we play Beethoven,
for some reason,
they're really amazed.
They're like, you guys don't
look like classical musicians.
And it made us
wonder, like, what
is it that people think
classical musicians look like?
Like, they wear old powdery
wigs still, or something?
I don't know.
So after a couple
of years of that,
we actually just got
more and more passionate
about spreading
the reality of what
it's like to be a
classical musician in 2018.
So we started filming
this documentary,
and here's the trailer.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Hello.
Hi.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Tonight is the Dover's album
release event for their very
first album called "Tribute."
This is a recording of
"Repertoire" by Mozart
that is paying tribute to
their mentors, the Guarneri
Quartet, which is one
of the great quartets
of the 20th century that
Dover was lucky enough
to study with members
of the Guarneri Quartet.
And this recording is
the same "Repertoire"
that the Guarneri recorded
on their debut disk,
and it's record exactly 50
years after that first album
came out.
Michael Tree and
Arnold Steinhardt,
the founding violist
and first violinist
of the Guarneri Quartet
will both be here tonight.
[MUSIC - DOVER QUARTET,
"REPERTOIRE"]
Next step for the
Dovers is for them
not to be somewhat of an
insider's secret in chair
music, and that is something
that's already changing.
They are starting to
play more and more
at really prominent
venues and with
these prominent
collaborators attracting
attention of major media.
I think they're going to become
a household name in the way
that not a lot of quartets have.
- [INAUDIBLE] up.
[CHEERING]
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
[CHEERING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- So just listening to how
masterfully you played that,
I think you really did succeed
and have this sense of ease
about your music-making.
So you're doing it.
[APPLAUSE]
- They have really become
the leading young string
quartet in the world.
And they play 120
concerts a year,
which is a schedule that very,
very few quartets maintain.
[CHEERING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MILENA PAJARO-VAN
DE STADT: All right.
So actually, you see a little
Kickstarter thing there.
We did launch a
successful Kickstarter,
and that's how we managed
to finish the filming
for the documentary.
And that trailer was
after one day of filming.
That was November
2016, I believe.
And now, we've done an
entire year of filming,
including in China, in
Austria, all over the world,
all over the place.
The types of things
that they were-- they
interviewed us,
and our colleagues,
and our mentors, and
presenters, and we get
into really personal things.
It's not just about
the job, I guess.
It's not just about the
performing, and the practicing,
and the rehearsing, but
also just the people
behind the music, and
our personal lives.
And they even interviewed
my fiance for, like,
three hours about it.
[LAUGHTER]
CAMDEN SHAW: Yeah, it was
a very personal experience,
and we're really
excited about it.
We did start a
nonprofit entity which
will be used partly for this
project, but in the future,
for commissions of new
works and things like that.
And if you're interested
in contributing
or being involved in some way,
don't hesitate to reach out.
Our email is also
really easy to remember.
It's just
Doverquartet@gmail.com.
Super easy.
So with that, let's
go to the Schumann,
this amazing, and just one
of the most successful piano
quintets ever written.
It's so catchy.
It's so joyful, and
exuberant, and very romantic.
And one thing that's
really cool about Schumann
is he almost always
found a way to work
his wife's name into his music.
So one theme that you'll
hear in this piece goes
[SINGING]
And then there's an
answer in the viola,
and we trade back and forth.
It's a very romantic duet,
but he gets the idea for the--
[SINGING]
From Clara, which he uses
in almost all of his pieces.
It's really incredible.
He was so in love with her.
And actually, he wrote
only three string quartets,
so the kind of things that we
could play without June's help.
And he wrote them all at once,
and they were all a birthday
gift to Clara, and
were premiered actually
at her birthday party in
their home in Leipzig, which
is very-- so he was a
very romantic person.
Schumann had a
pretty tragic life
and had some severe mental
health issues that escalated.
And eventually, he took his own
life, which is a great tragedy.
His output of music went from
really long patches of nothing,
no writing at all.
And then he would have the
year where he wrote, like,
a hundred incredible pieces.
This piece that we're about
to play the first moment of
was from one of
those great years.
He was definitely
on a high and was
writing like it was just the
most beautiful, natural thing
in the world.
So we're so excited to be
sharing the stage with June
and hope you enjoy this
great piece by Schumann.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC - DOVER QUARTET,
SCHUMANN'S PIANO QUINTET IN E
FLAT MAJOR, OPUS 44]
[APPLAUSE]
MILENA PAJARO-VAN DE STADT:
Let's give it up for June.
[CHEERING]
Yeah, June, woo.
So you might have noticed on
your programs if you have them,
it says "boarding" on there.
We were thinking
about it, and we
thought it would be
a better experience
to play a full work for you.
We had been toying with the
idea of only doing movements
of pieces here and there.
So we actually, instead
of doing the boarding,
we're going to do the entire
Mendelssohn quartet there we're
going to play for you, and
it's the one you see up
on the screen there.
Unfortunately, we
only have four of us
here, so we can't do the octet.
[LAUGHTER]
But yes, we're going to be doing
the entire Mendelssohn Opus 80,
and this is one of the
staples of the string quartet
literature.
It is a huge change of pace,
actually, from the Schumann
in terms of emotional
darkness and weight,
and it's actually the
last full major work
that Mendelssohn composed
two months before he died.
And the entire thing, actually
when he was first writing it,
I think at the top
somewhere, he had
written that it was
a requiem for Fanny,
which was his sister
who had recently died.
And that really tore him apart.
And you'll see when you hear
how tortured this piece is
that it was incredibly
emotional for him.
CAMDEN SHAW: It is.
Mendelssohn was a very
joyful person overall,
and extremely talented, actually
even more so than Mozart,
exhibited tremendous musical
skills at a young age.
Some of his most famous pieces
were composed in his teens,
actually, including the octet
that we are not playing today.
Really, really talented
person and very optimistic.
He was also a great
artist, actually.
In his home now-- you can still
visit it, and also in Leipzig,
actually--
is covered in his own
paintings, and they're
absolutely beautiful.
But this work is unusual
for him in that these themes
of darkness really pervade it.
And actually, three out
of the four movements
are downright angry
most of the time, just
really, really full of rage.
There are moments in all those
moments of respite from that,
but they're brief.
So it's a very dark and
very, very angry expression,
with the exception of the slow
movement, the third movement.
And it's almost as
if the entire piece
exists to set up this
experience of the slow movement.
It's incredibly plaintive,
and intimate, and vulnerable,
and it's really some of his
best writing that he ever did.
And actually, I
was telling Milena
I kind of wanted to share with
you guys one thing to listen
for in this piece and
specifically in this movement.
So one of the really cool things
about the music that we play
is the way that the
composers deliberately
change tiny little details for
a tremendous emotional meaning.
So in the slow moment,
there's a recurring thing
that you'll hear.
It's not a theme.
It's more like a word that
you'll hear over and over,
and it always goes like this.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And I really want you
guys to memorize it,
because there's only one time
where he says it differently,
and it's really important.
So can you guys all sing
along with me this thing?
[LAUGHTER]
Ready?
[SINGING]
So when he doesn't
do that, be amazed.
It's amazing.
So without further ado, this
incredible work by Mendelssohn.
Thanks again so
much for being here.
[MUSIC - DOVER QUARTET,
MENDELSSOHN'S QUARTET IN F
MINOR, OPUS 80]
[APPLAUSE]